Martin likes to
make flower bouquets
that each have 3
violets and 4 tulips.
If the price of a violet is V
and the price of a tulip is T,
match the expressions
to their meanings.
So let's see-- the price
of 1 of Martin's bouquets.
So one of Martin's bouquets
has 3 violets and 4 tulips.
So the 3 violets are
going to cost 3 times
the price of the
violet, which is V. So
that's the cost of
the violets, 3V.
And then the 4 tulips
are going to cost
4 times the price of a tulip.
So that's 4T.
So it's 3V plus 4T.
So it's not this one.
Let's see.
This one right over
here, this is 4T plus 3V.
So this is the price of 4
tulips, 4 times the price
of a tulip, plus 3 times
the price of a violet.
The price of 3 of
Martin's bouquets,
so it's essentially going
to be 3 times this quantity
right over here.
This is the price of 1 bouquet.
We want 3 of them.
So it's going to be 3 times
the quantity 4T plus 3V.
And let's see.
If I were to actually multiply
this out, 3 times 4T is 12T,
and then plus 3 times 3V is 9V.
So this is the same
thing if I were
to distribute the
3-- is 12T plus 9V.
Well, that's this
right over here.
These two are
equivalent expressions.
And let's see.
Are any of these other
things equivalent?
No, this says 3
times 3T plus 4V.
So I'm going to put this
in the not used bucket.
And then I have--
let's see-- 3V plus 2T.
I'm going to put it in
the not used bucket.
And let's see.
This has 2V plus 4T plus V.
So if I were to simplify this,
if I were to combine the V
terms-- if I have two V's and I
add another V, that's
three V's plus 4T.
So this is actually the
same thing as the price of 1
of Martin's bouquets.
So you could view this
as the price of 2 violets
plus the price of 4 tulips
plus another violet.
So it's really the price
of 3 violets and 4 tulips.
So let's check our answer.
We got it right.